before I begin would you please bow your
heads with me for prayer a simple prayer
from the Psalms let the words of my
mouth and the meditation of my heart be
acceptable in thy sight O Lord my
strength and my Redeemer
I pray this in Jesus dear name Amen it's
good to be back here in the Central
Valley I was born a few miles south of
here in LA I grew up a few miles north
of here and now I live many miles north
in the Walla Walla Valley over the
several decades of my life I've traveled
many of the roads and highways of this
beautiful state of California from the
intricate traffic patterns of Los
Angeles where I was born at White
Memorial Medical Center to the narrow
roads that explore the depths of Death
Valley to the hiking trails of the High
Sierras enjoying the grandeur of
Yosemite walking those soft sandy
beaches along the coast and no I didn't
climb the massive redwoods but I always
wanted to but how do we travel on these
same roads how do we get where we're
going and do we sometimes become
confused and lost and if we get lost
is there a trusty map in the glove box
to help us get to our destination as we
travel as you've noticed times are
changing and changing quickly today that
trusty old map lies in most glove boxes
in most cars dusty and creased and torn
unused many have turned to new gadgets
more exciting technologies of the day
some of us who grew up in the last
century are still trying to get used to
these new gadgets like computer
and so well but I'm just getting used to
a new one called the Global Positioning
System the GPS they started out as small
handheld devices and then we moved on to
devices installed in car computer
systems and now they're on almost
everybody's cell phone and if we want to
go at a certain place today all we have
to do is key in a current location and
then the new destination where you want
to travel to a friend of mine loaned me
a GPS for the trip down here and I flew
into Fresno and then drove down here to
Bakersfield well my friend has an ironic
sense of humor and he has the voice on
the GPS set you know there are many
voices on GPS you probably all know
about this more than I do because I'm
just getting used to it but the GPS that
this friend of mine has said on his GPS
was Homer Simpson and all the way from
Fresno from the airport and all the
windings to get out to 99 and then all
the way south and then all the way
through the little streets here to and
from in Bakersfield I have been
listening to Homer Simpson I'll get back
at my friend when I get home
within the GPS are embedded voices to
choose and you may choose either a male
voice or a female voice a great variety
of accents including your own former
governor called
Arnold the governador is the way it's
listed on the GPS information but some
of you might some of the ladies might
prefer those soothing Scottish brogue
with Sean Connery telling you where to
go
and then there's a more seductive voice
or there's a drill sergeant for the
military guys political voices are also
available some are George Bush some are
Barack Obama but they're not on the same
GPS with all these voices out there to
direct us I'd like to pose a simple
question who do we follow
there are many avenues to follow many
voices speaking to us in many different
ways and each of us is that a different
point in our own personal travel in our
relationship with God some of us are
determined to follow in the footsteps of
Christ some of us are still determining
what we believe others are doubting what
we believe some are dissecting some are
denying some are distracted some are
disinterested some are dismissive some
are disgusted and others are just about
done with it I would imagine that most
of us here have gone through a similar
process of thinking I know I have in my
life often wondering where to turn well
if you turn with me to proverbs 14:12
there is one very specific direction it
says there is a way that seemeth right
unto a man but the end thereof is the
way of death the key word to me is the
word seemeth the question is how do we
determine what
is right or what seems right do we
follow what we think do we follow what
our friends think do we follow what the
pastor thinks or do we search for a
source of truth that never fails turn
with me to John 14:6 this is where Jesus
says I am the truth the way the truth
and the life no man cometh unto the
father but by me God's Way leads to life
man's way leads to death the choice is a
simple one but a critical one it's life
or death so who do we follow Jesus
saying I am the way the truth and the
life there is only one way where do we
learn about that truth the scriptures
from Genesis to Revelation
each book of the Bible talks about
Christ's way this book is precious this
book is true and each of those books
should be studied what we study what we
choose to focus on is what we become
great controversy page 551 it is a law
not just a theory remember it is a law
both of the intellectual and the
spiritual nature by beholding we become
changed the mind gradually adapts itself
to the subjects upon which it is allowed
to dwell so we have a choice mrs. white
continues in volume 8 at the testimonies
in the future and that's right now in
the future Satan's superstitions will
assume new forms errors will be
presented in a pleasing and flattering
manner false theories will be presented
to deceive if possible the very elect
seducing influences will be exerted
Minds will be hypnotized corruptions
will be brought in to take Minds captive
under his deceptive influence not
Satan's influence men will have a form
of godliness without having a real
connection with God Satan satanic
agencies are instilling into human minds
that which in reality is deadly error
but what does Satan want in this final
controversy he knows that he cannot be
saved so he wants us to suffer with him
he wants our hearts but the heart is
merely an organ that pumps blood
throughout our body
in reality what Satan wants is our mind
and how will they get it let's look at
one of the most popular trends in the
world today this is in the secular world
we're not talking about the church at
the moment and that is mindfulness have
you heard the term has anyone heard
about mindfulness what it's about a few
of you Time magazine reports mindfulness
a revolution here is Times definition of
mindfulness a focused awareness of the
present moment a way of learning how to
focus on that thing that you were doing
and it's everywhere sounds innocuous at
first and Mac director of trend-spotting
for a marketing firm of JWT worldwide
defined it this way mindfulness is a
part of a much larger trend that we have
been observing called mindful living
it's a kind of counter trend to the past
decade of over stimulated ATD afflicted
tech saturated culture that we've been
living in that was once the domain of
the spiritual set and now it has
filtered into the mainstream
as more and more people are drawn to
this idea of shutting out distractions
and focusing just on the moment picture
if you will the World Economic Forum
it's a place crowded with high-powered
big-money delegates hundreds of members
having traveled from around the world to
a little town of Davos Switzerland a
picturesque village nestled in the Swiss
Alps a pristine picture perfect
definition destination the World
Economic Forum is composed of about a
thousand members of world's top
corporations global enterprises
political organizations each worth at a
minimum of 5 billion dollars and we're
talking big money and big influence
we're talking people like Klaus Schwab
who founded the World Economic Forum
Queen Rania of Jordan Samuel Huntington
an author and political scientist Angela
Merkel Chancellor of Germany David
Cameron Prime Minister of Great Britain
David Gates chairman of Microsoft just
to name a few
these corporate CEOs Nobel Prize winners
academics and politicians meet and then
suddenly the conference goes completely
silent there is a speaker at the podium
at the beginning of each day of this
World Economic Forum his name is Jon
kabat-zinn though he's educated as a
molecular biologist he is best known for
his work as an author and meditation
teacher he engages in bringing
mindfulness to the mainstream leaders in
medicine corporate leadership and
society his practice of yoga and studies
with Buddhist leaders including the
Dalai Lama have led him to integrate
mystical teachings into modern Western
culture now this is all secular has
nothing to do with Church
MBSR initials for mindfulness based
stress reduction is the program that
kabat-zinn offers to medical centers
hospitals health organizations as well
as the Economic Forum in Davos
Switzerland he leads them first into
silence instructing them on an awareness
of breath how they breathe when they
breathe instructing them in moments of
personal reflection teaching them the
importance of meditation how meditation
changes the brain and how it can affect
their effectiveness in the workplace and
they all want that they're eager for the
success therefore this offering them
effectiveness greater effectiveness is
enticing at this world economic
conference this timeframe at the
beginning of each day of the conference
it's a stark it reveals a stark contrast
to their frenzied high tension
atmosphere which suddenly becomes
tranquillity time media reports say that
these techniques though once considered
to be radical a fringe thing have now
become incorporated into academics
medicine science and much more in our
world in recent years the meditation
within this strictly secular environment
of this world economic conference has
grown more and more prominent companies
including General Mills Aetna Blackrock
are teaching meditation to their
employees students at Harvard Medical
School can take classes on mindful
leadership and even Goldman Sachs is
doing it just to name a few
want you to think about what you see up
on the screen here
mindfulness according to this teacher
dr. kabat-zinn is paying attention to
the present moment with intention while
letting go of judgment as if your life
depends
on it think about that if you let go of
your judgment does your life depend on
it yes it could be critical to your life
you never let go of your judgment you
never let go of your mind to any other
spirit early each morning at the eight
o'clock session kabat-zinn leads these
powerful leaders into the period of
silence and I quote he says it's to get
the delegates out of their heads he
describes it in another way the first
thing we notice when we practice
mindfulness is how mindless we are
paying attention only in the present
moment non-judgmentally this is far from
a bible-based meditation it's Buddhist
based meditation that has been
secularized for the modern Western man
however the secularization of these
methods does not include informing these
intent attendees of the inherent dangers
of mindfulness under the newly
established term of mindfulness our
secular culture is now being introduced
into a mystical meditation as an
acceptable method as an acceptable
method of improving life it mirrors an
entire society shift toward meditation
it is becoming part of the mainstream
it shows modern science validating an
ancient wisdom that is dangerous and a
quote from the media we are living
through a major tipping point this is
far from any meditation taught in the
Bible and it's being done purely for
secular reasons reasons within a modern
setting only to enhance business
practices to enhance interpersonal
dynamics but what is behind the practice
the names are changed but the methods
are exactly the same its ancient
mysticism which alters the mind
who wants your mind think does these
aspects of the mind being introduced
into many outlets or society are not
just corporate though they're in
hospitals they're in sports training
programs they're in military training
programs and the a military rehab and
even more important they're in our
schools they're in our schools
mindfulness has been cleverly integrated
into our public schools despite the fact
that we are not to teach legally
according to our constitution now we're
not to teach any kind of religious
practices in our public schools
but today's mindfulness though
originally taken from mystical tradition
has now been secularized and it's
promoted in many schools nationwide The
Associated Press reports Western culture
has secularized this centuries-old
religious practice but what does it mean
to secularize mindfulness it boils down
to a simple change in vocabulary
promoters drop the terms Buddhism and
meditation and they add the terms
neuroscience and scientific research but
the practices taught in public schools
and Buddhists temples are exactly the
same in Portland Oregon Oregon high
school
mindfulness programs feature a program
called peace in schools it's director
was trained by Zen Buddhist in a
monastery for eight years and it boasts
of being the very first for-credit
mindfulness program in high schools u.s.
high schools but it's not just up in
Portland Oregon's been doing their own
thing for a long time right it's right
here in California
Trudy Goodman founder of insite la
speaking about her educational program
which is incorporated into the coupling
schools
she says secular mindful
for public schools is really stealth
Buddhism whether they want it or not
incite teachers have taught thousands of
students about mindful meditation over a
period of ten years of service to the
people in the Los Angeles area and
although the secular classes use a
different vocabulary getting children to
engage in the same practices of
mindfulness that is taught in Buddhist
classrooms they get it whether they want
it or not these statements were taken
from an audio portion of an interview by
Trudi Goodman in which she and others
involved in life this this discussion
laughed audibly at the deception that
they were achieving but hers is not the
only avenue for education there is a new
name in the area of California education
one that has made some startling changes
she explains her tactics adding a 2013
mind heart conference in the Dalai Lama
center for peace education she
introduced a program for elementary
children called mind up it's a new
internationally disseminated curriculum
for elementary education this new
education leader here in California
spoke of her goal she says we have been
able to bring contemplative practice
into the classroom under a different
name obviously people say oh meditation
and they think this is Buddhism to
achieve this goal
she chose to use other terms like core
practice and brain breaks instead of
traditional terminology who is this new
name in California education you might
be surprised
it's Goldie Hawn
I remember her from Latvia in the 60s
she was the socket to me girl does
anyone remember Goldie Hawn when she was
very very young somehow I never did
imagine her as an educator of our
children Goldie Hawn started with the
Hawn foundation in 2005 recruiting
educators neuroscientists psychologists
all to work with Buddhist meditators
they developed this program of might the
mindfulness curriculum which was
published in partnership with scholastic
books in 2011 when speaking to Buddhist
co-religionist Han says mind up all
started with His Holiness the Dalai Lama
the Dalai Lama who gave Goldie Hawn her
own personal mantra and it started for
her at the Dalai Lama center but in
presenting her program to the public in
Washington DC at the Press Forum she
said no there is no Buddhism in there
she said I am Jewish I would not present
Buddhism the names are changed but the
methods are the same
she is just teaching them how the brain
works and this particular elementary
curriculum mind up is now installed and
active in more than 1,000 elementary
schools across this country these are
your children that we're talking about
these are your children
according to Han children can't face the
world we live in without these tools the
children are taught two distinctive
concepts vital to the core practice
children must participate in deep belly
breathing and attentive listening
mindfulness meditation is led in the
classroom by teachers three times a day
students are instructed on the focus of
their breathing and cultivating
non-judgmental awareness of passing
thoughts and emotions non-judgmental in
other words don't make a decision on
issues just let it go don't look at
something with critical thinking and say
this is right or this is wrong don't be
judgmental there is a constant
repetition in her classes of the word
mindfulness it points children and
parents to places where they can go for
resources for deeper meditation as they
google the term mindfulness it yields an
abundance of explicitly Buddhist books
and classes and retreat centers that
they can go to is this the kind of
education you want for your children but
you may say my children are in Seventh
day Adventist schools people they're not
all in Adventist schools over 60% of our
seventh-day Adventist young people are
in public education and they need
protection they need to be aware that
mindfulness is being taught mindfulness
in the guise of being good but still the
old methods of the old world
we are concerned about our children when
we speak of educating the mind but what
about our own personal study most of us
here as adults that's vital to our own
growth in our church and in what we
believe and when we do choose things for
our own personal study there is one wise
thing that I believe all of us should do
before we ever choose a book now let's
read the introduction the introduction
of a book generally informs the reader
of several key elements what the book is
about who the book is about who is the
author and what is the author's source
since the day of the first lie on this
earth Satan has been sharpening his
skills honing deceptive techniques and
he's doing it through every avenue
possible even more so now this certainly
includes the materials we read it was
about a year ago last Christmas that a
friend of mine handed me a beautiful
little book that she'd just been given
for her daily personal worship it's a
softly padded book with a beautiful
palette a few of autumn colors blending
deep earth and browns and bright
tangerine at the center of the cover is
an oval frame focused on an outstretched
outstretched hand the book Jesus calling
by Sarah Young has a comforting subtitle
enjoying the peace of his presence this
attractive little book is perfectly
sized for bedside table use it's just
four by six inches it's laid out in an
easy read page a day format for personal
study it appeared to be a beautiful gift
but my friend said Janet there's
something I can't quite put my finger on
she says I don't know what it is but
something isn't right
so she gave the book to me and she said
will you take a look at it so I turned
the book over and the first paragraph I
read on the back of the
book was this this is young sorry young
the author young decided to be more
attentive to the Savior's voice and
began listening quote to what he was
saying
so with pen in hand she embarked on a
journey that forever changed her life
and many others around the world now it
was not just my friend that was
concerned I became concerned too so I
turned to the introduction of the book a
smart thing to do find out what's in it
and the source of what's in it the very
first words in the introduction she
talks about the presence of God and
setting a beautiful exquisite beauty in
a fairyland environment Young had an
experience when she was in a small
French Alpine village all alone on a
moonlit walk through the snow she
describes this suddenly I felt as if a
warm mist enveloped me I became aware of
a lovely presence and my involuntary
response was sweet Jesus pondering this
mystical experience and several other
similar ones the author stated that
these experiences were far more than the
intellectual answers for which she had
been actually searching this was a
relationship with the creator of the
universe and then Jung described began
what she described as a new spiritual
quest a quest in which she included
intensive study of another book a book
that had been written back in the 30s
called God calling but what was the
source of God calling it's a New Age
devotional book it sold over 10 million
sounds great right it was compiled by a
man by the name of AJ Russell in the
early 30s it was put together by two
anonymous British women and still
anonymous no
knows who they are they identified
themselves only as two listeners and
claimed to have received messages given
to them by the living Christ himself the
ritual of the 2 listeners practiced was
sitting quietly pencil and paper in hand
and waiting for messages and then
carefully recording them Sarah young the
author of Jesus calling having
diligently studied their book and their
practices became intrigued with the
messages from God calling and proclaimed
that book as a treasure she continued
her quest and she wondered if she liked
those two listeners could also receive
direct messages from God she reveals
this in the introduction of her book
Jesus calling this is Sarah young in her
own words talking about how she received
her messages I had been waiting I had
been writing in prayer journals for
years but that was one-way communication
I did all the talking I knew that God
created communicated with me through the
Bible but I yearned for more
increasingly I wanted to hear what God
had to say to me personally on a given
day I listened we decided to listen to
God with pen in hand just like the two
anonymous ladies writing down whatever I
believed God was singing I felt awkward
at the first time but I received a
message my journaling had now changed
from monologue to dialogue soon messages
began flowing more freely the key Bible
text claimed by Sarah gong throughout
her new spiritual quest was this Psalm
46:10 I'm sure you all know what that is
be still and know that I am God these
are God's words be still and know that I
am God
however Sarah young carefully chose her
own alternative words to this text God's
words were changed to relax and know
that I am God let go and know that I am
God
cease striving and know that I am God
are we allowed to change rearrange
select alternative words for the Bible
is that our prerogative I don't believe
so
yet Sarah young somehow feels that she
is allowed she described her experience
as an enticing invitation from God to
lay down the cares and seek his presence
this practice of listening to God had
increased my intimacy with him more than
any other spiritual discipline the
author's monologues became dialogues
that she claimed were from God and then
they were transcribed into the
first-person singular the I Me Mine each
word is read as being spoken directly by
Jesus in the way she writes it in this
format she causes her reading readers to
perceive that each word is spoken by
Jesus in essence creating her own red
letter version of the Bible although she
liberally includes scriptural quotations
Jung admits to personally paraphrasing
many texts and then she continues to
uniquely instruct her readers so that
they can - can receive the same kind of
messages each reader must do this you
must sit with pen in hand read her
messages messages from her book jesus
calling slowly and in a quiet place wait
for the literal presence of Jesus wait
to receive messages personal messages
from
him even though young claims a total
acceptance of the Bible she readily
states
she is not satisfied with just the
scriptures she said I was yearning for
more do we need more than the scriptures
from this kind of an entity where you
sit and then write down whatever comes
into your mind who is coming into your
mind who is taking your mind at that
moment her self-described yearning for
more and her insistence on personal
daily messages from God opened her to
the same channelled source as the two
anonymous visitors who authored the book
Jesus God calling is this the way Jesus
communicates today let's be honest and
call it what it really is it's New Age
theology it's a form of channeling it's
spiritual dictation but it's now dressed
up in an acceptable 21st century garb a
New Age theology there Jesus is not the
same Jesus a Bible there is another
Jesus there's a counterfeit warn be
Smith a former New Ager an author of
five books on spiritual deception
recently published a sixth book he
called it another Jesus calling he
evaluates what Sarah Jung wrote he
documents significant concerns about
Sarah's book Smith says Jesus calling
seems to be an obvious attempt by our
spiritual adversary to get an even
further foothold into the Christian
Church is the Jesus of Jesus calling the
biblical Jesus Christ or is that false
or is it a false Christ deceiving many
the unusual language of the Jesus seems
to run the gambit from everyday Joe
language to strange word choice
unwarranted flattery worldly cliches
repetitive phrases disparaging comments
and not-so-subtle mockery Smith
continues in his evaluation of Jesus
calling by the end of the book its Jesus
and subtly and not so subtly introduced
a cult New Age channeling spiritual
dictation creative visualization
meditation and divine outcome II
co-creation with God and practicing the
presence like it was every day Christian
fare historically we as seventh-day
Adventists know that in 1844 Jesus
Christ entered into the most holy temple
most holy place of the heavenly
sanctuary his work there is
all-consuming Christ's work today does
not include suddenly exiting the most
holy place when someone says I yearned
for more Adam and that he come down to
us such messages which include the warm
mist enveloping a person or pending
personal messages upon demand are not
from Jesus Christ the Son of God though
this statement may offend some longtime
devotees of Sarah young Warren Smith
Ruth Graham lighthouse trails all non
Adventists have been speaking for years
about their concerns of her writings but
no one is listening in the ten years
since Jesus calling was written it has
quickly climbed the book charts it's
number one at the top of all selling
Christian books number three on Wall
Street Journal's bestseller list and
that's for all non-fiction books
religious and secular it's available in
nearly all Christian bookstores over 10
million copies have been sold but
despite the long-term financial success
with all those books
old young and her publisher have now
unexpectedly made some significant
changes and omissions to her book the
new publications of the same book in the
future will not include her experience
of how he she received her mystical
messages those will be omitted it will
not include her experience of the
intimate study of the book God calling
which she once called the treasure it
will not use the terms messages to
describe her writings but rather they
will revise it to say these are writings
and devotions it's an attempt to depict
her writings with a less mystical
inflected terminology their actions
deceptively reveal efforts to move an
increasingly controversial bestseller
away from its initial new-age origin
into mainstream Christian orthodoxy and
you say why should we as Adventists be
concerned about Jesus calling
seventh-day adventists need to be aware
that despite the author's admitted
new-age history Sarah Young's books are
being prominently displayed and sold at
many Adventist bookstores
across our country there are 41 ABC's
currently in the contiguous United
States 65% of these bookstores sell
Jesus calling and I would venture to say
there are people here in this audience
today who may have it on their bedside
tables and not be aware I'm not asking
you to raise your hands
some have but I won't won't point you
out
the question is did you read the
introduction all of the information I
give had give a giving you is in the
introduction to the book most people
open the book and go right to the first
page January 1 because I said day by day
study all the way through the year in my
local ABC I counted 13 different cover
designs from which to choose
hardcover cushion cover soft cover
spiral cover rainbow of colors in
numerous sizes some targeting the youth
some targeting the children more than
all the other devotional books in the
entire store in that entire ABC more
than all the other SDA and non SDA
devotional books combined pastures by
multiple copies of Jesus calling for
church employees and give them to them
as Christmas gifts Adventist families
buy these books in bulk for all the
relatives in the in the family giving
what appears to be the perfect gift to
encourage daily study are you reading
channelled devotions to your children
who is sending the messages in Jesus
calling is this the way God talks to or
pious people today do you want to give
over your mind to that study who do you
follow how do you select a worship book
by its attractive cover by its number
one top selling sales status or a
friend's recommendation Isaiah 8:20 says
to the law and to the testimony if they
speak not according to this word it is
because there is no light in them I'd
like to turn just briefly to conclude
toward another phenomenon that is coming
into many seventh-day Adventist churches
today and if you haven't seen it yet you
probably will soon
and that is the use of darkness in the
sanctuary darkness is now being used
regularly in many meeting houses
churches and temples Protestant Catholic
and now Adventists
it is best described by nationally known
emergent church thought leader and
author of the book emerging the emerging
church Dan Kimball on page 136 Dan
Kimball speaks about darkness and this
is what he says in our culture it is
becoming more multi-sensory and less
respectful of God we have a
responsibility to pay more attention to
the design of the space where we
assemble regularly in the emerging
culture darkness represents spirituality
we see this in Buddhist temples as well
as Catholic and Orthodox churches
darkness communicates that something
serious is happening does this sound
like a new path we should follow with
Kimball statement in mind I would like
you to I would like to look directly
into one of our own churches for a few
moments and some of the words spoken
there if you will use your imagination
for a few moments with me it's a
beautiful spring morning the sun is
shining it's Sabbath and we walk into a
large seventh-day Adventist Church the
church with a membership of about 2400
members is filled with a congregation a
mix of local community members and
university students a scripture is read
Kym's are sung prayers are prayed and
the children have heard their story and
then the pastor steps onto the platform
he speaks about prayer about closing our
eyes when we pray about being in the
darkness about Jesus have
of praying in the darkness as he speaks
the lights slowly dim and we noticed the
shades are being adjusted to create a
completely darkened sanctuary and then
you remember that even those tiny little
vertical windows in the doors at the
back of the sanctuary were taped with
black paper the pastor calmly assures
the congregation that this is not an
attempt to be cute or clever but that
thinking about prayer in the dark will
help us to understand why Jesus valued
it so my question is this where does it
say that Jesus valued the dark I
couldn't find that answer the pastor
then calmly assured the congregation
that this is not attempt to be clever
somehow I've got a duplicate slide in
here I'm sorry the congregation is then
gradually submerged into total darkness
some small children become wet Restless
and begin to fuss a bit and have to be
taken out
but then the Matt the pastor a master
wordsmith a skilled orator known for his
ability to memorize entire sermons
begins to speak through the darkness for
the next twenty two minutes so as long
as you see that script above that dark
square on the screen you imagine that
you are in darkness in the seventh-day
Adventist Church
he begins in Genesis with a creation
story urging the congregation to think
of the presence of darkness the pastor
says God created out of darkness day one
God creates light but also affirms
darkness my question is this where does
it say God affirms the darkness I
couldn't find that one either
however when you go to the scripture in
Genesis one three and four it says God
said let there be light and there was
light and God saw that the light saw the
light that it was good and God divided
the light from the darkness he did not
affirm the darkness he continues
speaking about the creation week the
pastor said the seventh day begins at
sunset at the beginning of darkness the
first half of the Sabbath lived in the
pitch black of night where in the bible
does it say anything about the pitch
black of night during Sabbath obviously
the world you know is turning on its
axis and we have times of light and dirt
but the focus of the Sabbath has nothing
to do with darkness
the pastor continues talking about the
children of Israel God leads the
children of Israel through the waters of
a parted sea at night going through the
Red Sea yes it happened at night but why
leave the emphasis on the darkness when
the scripture says there was a pillar of
cloud that came between the camp of the
Egyptians and the camp of Israel it came
at cloud of darkness to the Egyptians
and it gave light to the Israelites God
does not leave his people in darkness
but they enter the emphasis by the
pastor is the waters parted at night no
emphasis on God's leading light the
pillar that gave them the ability to
move Moses the pastor says ascend the
mountain to hear the word to hear a word
from God we are told that there is a
dark cloud that shrouds the mountain
leaving the people as it were left in
the dark
but the scripture says that this
particular cloud was given as protection
so that they would not that Israelites
would not be killed
by God's glory there was a protective
cloud they were not left down there in
darkness they were left in protective
care by God do you see a pattern here
darkness is wonderful darkness is
preferred while God HT s stone his law
in stone the Ten Commandments God's
chosen people were at the foot of the
mountain protected not in darkness but
still sitting in darkness the converse
the congregation then sees the first bit
of light appearing on the screen
with this message are you seeing that
message this is not from the Bible so
far we have not heard any scriptures we
have heard references to scriptures and
reinterpretation of scriptures possibly
even the twisting of scriptures but now
we get to our first quote on the screen
which is the only light that you see in
the middle of this 22 minutes of
darkness and this is the quote this
darkness and the cloud is always between
you and God
no matter what you do and it prevents
you from seeing him clearly by the light
of your reason and from experiencing him
in sweetness of love and your affection
so set yourself to rest in this darkness
as long as you can always crying out
after him whom you love for if you are
to experience him or see him at all in
so far as it is possible here it must
always be in this cloud in this darkness
this is a very strange cloud being
presented it's from a book called the
Cloud of Unknowing anybody know what the
Cloud of Unknowing is all about does
anyone ever read about that yes
the cloud of the unknowing is a document
written in the 14th century by an
anonymous monk very very prestigious
scholars describe this book as full of
the best and brightest teachings of the
mystical desert fathers of old the
underlying message urges that the only
way to know God is to abandon all
preconceived notions and beliefs or
knowledge about God to be courageous
enough to surrender your mind and ego to
the realm of unknowing at which point
you begin to glimpse the true nature of
God who is this that once your mind
who wants our minds Satan does this
anonymous monk urges us to rest in
darkness as long as you can is that
someone we can follow the pastor
continues still in darkness he urges
close your eyes when you pray for we
walk not by sight but by faith now
that's true but he says in closing your
eyes we affirm that we will trust God
even in the darkness close your eyes
when you pray because quote in the
darkness you shall see more clearly we
see more clearly in the darkness where
is this yearning from darkness coming
from you you got the agenda here so far
John 12:46 says I am the light I am come
a light unto the world that whosoever
believeth on me should not abide in
darkness Psalm 27:1 the Lord is my light
and my salvation whom shall I fear but
the pastor continues there is something
about the night that brings forth
communication with God and severs the
divine
between humans and the divine night
brings forth communication with God the
posture then says in the darkness you
can be closer to God but the scripture
says first John 1:5 God is light and in
him is no darkness at all he then went
through a litany and I'll go through
this very very quickly because it's long
Abraham things happen to him in the dark
Jacob Joseph Samuel Daniel Jonah in that
he was in the dark for three days in the
whale Paul was blinded the pastor
continues there is something about
closing one's eyes that expands our
capacity to taste the pastor continues
the biblical record suggests that we
experience God more acutely in the dark
there is no such text to verify this
assertion only the subtle wording of the
speaker now astronomy tells us that the
Earth revolves once every 24 hours
therefore 50% of our lives are lived
without the benefit of direct sunlight
but how does that establish that we
experience God more acutely in the dark
Isaiah says woe to them that call evil
good and good evil that put darkness for
light and light for darkness the pastor
continues then with a reference to a
particular author a lady by the name of
Barbara brown Taylor a renowned
Episcopal preacher and author of the
book called learning to walk in the dark
surprise in her book Barbara brown
Taylor says this that we are to put
aside our fears and our anxieties to
explore all that God has to teach us in
the dark
through darkness Taylor says we find a
courage we understand the world in new
ways we feel God's presence around us
guiding us through things seen and
unseen God dwells in deep darkness God
comes to people in dark clouds dark
nights dark dreams and dark strangers
God does some of God's best work in the
dark
the pastor continues saying her writings
have blessed me on the value of darkness
he then reiterates closed your eyes with
prayer sweet hour of prayer then there
was silence you're still sitting in
darkness twenty-two minutes of darkness
and then there was silence for another
two minutes twenty four hundred people
sitting in the congregation and then the
service ended
it is significant to note that in barber
tater Browns writings we find a nearly
identical structure to the sermon
presented by this pastor with a constant
emphasis on darkness throughout both the
old and the New Testaments it was
featured in Time magazine on the very
weekend that the pastor presented it
this was not even a seventh-day
Adventist sermon it was excerpted from
an Episcopal sermon from her writings
this woman listed among the most the 100
100 most influential people in the world
today good credentials but not biblical
credentials the pastor affirms her
writings have blessed me on the value of
darkness
what is the literal value of darkness
now this is me talking darkness is
merely the absence of light in darkness
nothing grows no flowers no fruit no
grains in darkness there is no sight the
human eye when kept in darkness will
eventually atrophy and become blind for
us to function as human beings light
must be added what is the value of light
there is growth there are flowers and
fruits and grains light allows for true
vision physically and spiritually light
enhances life whereas darkness hubble's
it darkness is what not what enhances
prayer it is the quiet uninterrupted
time that we choose to spend with God
that enhances prayer now let me ask you
a question from back in grade school how
fast does light travel huh how many
thousand miles per second
everybody knows that hundred and eighty
six thousand miles per second that's
fast that's powerful next question how
fast is darkness trouble zero miles per
second where is the power is the power
in the darkness or in the light light I
have to give you my favorite text one of
my favorite texts and this applies to
this particular subject ye are a chosen
generation a royal priesthood a holy
nation a peculiar people that she should
show forth the praises of him who called
you out of darkness into this marvelous
light
that's first Peter 2:9 who is teaching
whom here why are we hearing messages in
darkness advocating darkness preached in
the seventh-day Adventist Church why is
the only visible quote on the screen
before the congregation a message from a
14th century monk why do we go to an
Episcopal priest for a sermon and why is
this being presented to our youth page
587 of the great controversy says it is
one of Satan's devices to combine with
falsehood just enough truth to give it
plausibility Satan is constantly
endeavoring to attract attention to man
in place of God he leads people to look
to bishops to pastors to professors of
theology as their guides instead of
searching the Scriptures to learn their
duty for themselves then by controlling
the minds of these leaders he can
influence the multitudes to do his will
I am personally very fortunate
to have a pastor who preaches from the
Bible and he preaches with all the
lights on
once a month without fail he begins his
sermon with a very powerful statement
and the moment he begins this statement
there is immediate hush in our
congregation because we all know and
appreciate what he's about to say it is
this the Bible is the fully inspired
Word of God it is the infallible
revelation of his will it is the
authoritative revealer of doctrine and
it is the trustworthy record of God's
acts in history prayerfully and humbly
read and study the Bible more for in it
we find hope for every crisis but more
importantly we will find our Lord Jesus
Christ who died to redeem us from our
sins do you believe that friends yes
it's all about the Bible it's about
God's truth and God's direction and
ultimately eternal life and for us as a
church it's about family
for me I have two grown sons and one
daughter in love to me the term
daughter-in-laws a little too legalistic
I like to call her a daughter in love it
sounds a little bit more like family and
I also have three grandchildren they're
all teenagers now and they're all in
home school and we all live in the same
little town right near that University
where my grandchildren may go to school
one day but in that University Church
the preacher preaches in darkness and I
have to ask the question now who do we
follow it's about family your children
and my children your grandchildren my
grandchildren it's about all of us
following God's will
to do that we must do these three things
verify all that we see in here with the
Scriptures determine that we will follow
only in the direction that those
scriptures instruct and listen to God's
voice no matter what other voices may
say my parents gave me my first grown-up
Bible when I was 14 years old I can't
use it for everyday study anymore
because I have to keep a band around it
to hold it together but I always take it
with me when I travel because it helps
to remind me where I want to go and how
I need to get there and who I want to
meet and I promise to meet my parents
there one day my mother usually wrote
all the letters and cards and
correspondences but my father was the
one that wrote in front of this Bible
and she and he wrote this to me to Janet
on her 14th birthday from mother and dad
made this good book help us to meet
together in the holy city very simple
but to me it's very very precious and
like I said I carry it with me when I
travel even though it's not easy to keep
it together but this particular
statement is one that I would like to
present to you I'm sure all of you have
the same desire to meet loved ones in
the holy city someday and you want to
meet there with your children and every
one of us has to make a decision as to
who we're going to follow and the only
way we're going to know how to get there
is to follow this road map
the GPS may take you off on a strange
route they're not protected they're not
well those little devices are not
completely perfect yet they may be
someday but there are voices telling us
to go many different directions but
there is one voice here we can always be
sure of so I pray that we can all meet
together in the holy city with my family
and your family but right now the choice
is ours
as to whom we follow and that must be
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ and
this is the road map to get us there
shall we bow our heads please our
gracious Father in heaven we thank you
so much for your word we thank you for
your love and for your grace I pray that
we will honor you by studying what you
have given to us your scriptures so that
we might be with you in heaven in the
name we pray
you